from a psychology from a neuroscience
perspective this whole construction that
you've developed is fascinating
we did this a little bit with autonomous
vehicles
so to try to understand the decision
making process of a pedestrian when they
cross the road and trying to create an
experience
of a car you know that can run you over
so there's the danger
of there i was so surprised
how real that whole world was
and the graphics that we built wasn't
ultra realistic or anything but
i was still afraid of being hit by a car
but everybody we tested were really
afraid of being hit by that car even
though it was all a simulation it was
all simulation it was uh
it was kind of boxy actually i mean it
wasn't like
ultra realistic simulation and it's
fascinating
looms and heights so any kind of depth
we're just programmed to um
to not necessarily recoil but to be
cautious about that edge and that depth
and then looms things coming at us that
are getting larger there are looming
sensing neurons even in the retina
at the very very early stage of visual
processing
and incidentally uh the way
mueller and you know folks learn how to
not get eaten by great white sharks when
you're swimming outside the cage
is as they start lumbering in you swim
toward them
and they get very confused when you loom
on them
because clearly you're smaller clearly
they could eat you if they wanted to
but there's something about forward
movement toward
uh any creature that that creature
questions whether or not it would be a
good idea
to generate forward movement toward you
and so that's actually the survival tool
of these cage exit white shark divers
are you playing around with like one of
the critical things for the autonomous
vehicle research
is you couldn't do 360 video because the
there's a game theoretic there's an
interactive element that's really
necessary
so maybe people realize this maybe they
don't but
360 video you obviously
well it's actually not that obvious to
people but you can't change
the reality that you're watching that's
right so
uh but you find that that's
like is there something fundamental
about fear and stress
that the interactive element is
essential for or do you find you can
you can arouse people with just the
video great question
um it works best to use mixed reality
so we have a snake stimulus i personally
don't like snakes
at all i don't mind spiders we also have
a spider stimulus but like snakes
i just don't like them there's something
about the slithering and
it just it creates a visceral response
for me
um some people not so much and they have
lower levels of
stress and fear in there but one way
that we can get them
to feel more of that is to use mixed
reality
where we have a an actual physical bat
and they have to stomp out the snake as
opposed to just
walk to a little safe corner which then
makes the snake disappear
that tends to be not as stressful as if
they have a physical weapon
and so you've got people in there you
know banging on the floor against this
thing
and there's something about engaging
that makes it more of a
more of a threat now i should also
mention that we we always get the
subjective report
from the subject of what they experience
because
i we never want to project our own ideas
about what they were feeling but that's
the beauty of working with humans is you
can ask them how they feel
exactly and humans aren't great at
explaining how they feel
um but it's a lot easier to understand
what they're saying than
a mouse or a macaque monkey is saying um
so it's the best we can do is language
plus these physiological and
neurophysiological signals
you